με το τραγούδι δεν θα αγανομιά δουλειά το πρωί και το βράδυ θα επηγαίνω να
τραγουδό είναι σε επίπεδα σήμερα οι κύπρο στα μαθας ιά να προσφέρουν σε ένα παιδί
πουείναι το όνιρο του αυτό να κάνει μόνο αυτό είναι ξέρω κάθε ίδος δουλιάς πόδως
περιστής να είς δεπείο πορίζεσ από την κύπρο ι οπορίζεσ τώραν μέσα σύγηση και προς
το εξοδεριικό για να ανοίξει καργιέρασου ι ένα συθε οποιώσι ένας τραουδιστείσεί ένας παρουσιαστείς το
ότι δήποτε σίγουσε κάποιες άλλες χώρες μεγαλύτερες είναι περισσότεριτριδί περισσότεριη εμπιρία σου δίνει και περισσότερες
γνώσεις καιεχέκια από κεί και πέρα θεωρώ ότη ναι μπορεί ένα τραγουδιστς να βγ οποριστεί
και να σας ειμο τραουδιστήις να βι οποριστεί γιατί υπάρχουν επιλογιές ώστε να μημφικε στο
εξιτορικό να μηνηστην κύπρο υπάρχουν τα μαχαζια υπάρχει αυτός εξαυτά τη θέλει ο καθένας τη
σιαμου εγώ θεωρώ ότι υπάρχει ναι υπάρχουν μαγας για υπάρχουν χώρι υπάρχει ταβάνει στην κύπρο
αλλά προχθές περνούσαμε τα υτοκίνηδόμου κάπου στου κειδονιά μας κεί στην έγκομε και πιανικόκκινο φανάρι
και κάνω έτσι α συνέστερα και βλέπο μια γριά ευδόμηντα πέντε περίπο γρόντα χρό και
ένα σιδερώνι στομαγαζί που σιδερώη ρούχα ένιωσα των εααυτό μου όχι των ένιωσα έτρεξε το
δάκριμου γιατί είμαι λίγο αυσυγκίνητος αυτά ιδικά σε πεδάγια και μεγάλης υλιγίας και βλέω τες
αυτός ο άνθρωπος ας πούμε σε αυτό μαγαζί τόσα χρόνια να σιδερώνιτα ρούχα του κάθενός
άλλο ας πούμε όταν μπορεί να επιπιώνι ένας άνθρωπος τέτοιος που ίσως να ναι πέντε
έξι δέκα ευρώ το κάθεαυτό γιατί να μην επιπιώσει ένας καλιτέχνεις που θα ξεκινήσει από
εκατό πενίτα γιακόβρομεροκάματο